votre gilet de sauvetage se trouve dans
une pochette sous votre siège si son
utilisation solaire nécessaire
a mené les sangles autour de votre
taille tirer sur les sangles
jusqu'à ce que le gilet soit bien ajusté
comme nous vous le montre
merci de votre attention
nous allons bientôt décoller
[Applaudissements]
des événements nous déchire en morceaux
j'aime être soulès c'est ce que ça veut
dire
et quelqu'un et remet en place divers
pourquoi le jeu parfois on peut être
celle des deux planètes c'est dur d'être
se lavent commun et attention qu'est ce
qui te dis que je ne suis pas un seul
type
je sais rien
[Musique]
tu es spéciale
qu'est ce que t'en sais
c'est difficile d'être heureusement
je pense que je vais finir fallait
personne n'utilise son visage public
dans ce genre de lieu
parfois nous masquent plus joli que ce
qui se trouve derrière
je me dis qu'il n'ya pas de fin heureuse
toutes les pièces ne s'emboîtent pas
parfaitement
et d'un coup tout est pas
[Musique]